solve for x plus 8 is less than or equal
to 6 and graph the solution so we have X
plus 8 is less than or equal to 6
so let's solve this inequality for X and
the easiest way to isolate an X on let's
isolate on the left hand side since it's
already there is to just get rid of this
8 and the best way to get rid of this
positive 8 is to subtract 8 from both
sides so let's subtract 8 from both
sides that won't change the direction of
the inequality so the left-hand side X
plus 8 minus 8 you're just left with an
X the right-hand side 6 minus 8 is
negative 2 and we still have the less
than or equal so we solve the inequality
we have X is less than or equal to
negative 2 so let's draw that on a
number line so let's so that's my number
line let's stick 0 over here maybe if we
go 1 and then we could go negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 and we could keep
going to the left and we want all the
X's that are less than or equal to
negative 2 since we're eat since it can
be equal to negative 2 we'll put a
filled-in line right here at negative 2
and all of the values less than that if
it was just less than if there wasn't
the equal sign we would have an open dot
but since there's less than or equal to
we've closed this dot and then we want
all of the values below that all of the
values below that and you could just
sample a few and verify for yourself
that they work based on this negative 3
should work and if you took negative 3
negative 3 plus 8 is 5 which is
definitely less than 6 so that works and
negative 1 shouldn't work it's not
included in this set over here so let's
try that out negative 1 negative 1 plus
8 is 7 which is definitely not less than
6 so just sampling some points it seems
like we've got the right solution